Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna do some dabbling and experimentation
with some new Pulumi features that enable multi
language packages.
Before we get started with that, there's just
a little bit of housekeeping. But first, if
you're not subscribed to the channel, please do
so now and remember to click the bell
so you get loads of notifications for all
new episodes
as we explore the vast cloud native landscape
together.
And if you wanna chat and talk cloud
native Kubernetes and NFN in between, we have
a very active Discord server. Feel free to
pop in there, say hello, and I look
forward to meeting you.
Alright. Now joining me today to introduce me
to this wonderful Pulumi awesomeness
is a returning guest, Lee Briggs, man. How's
it going?
Not so bad. How are you? Yeah. I'm
I'm doing well. I'm looking forward to seeing
what new shiny stuff you've got kicked up
for us today.
Yeah. This is really
new, so really, really on the cutting edge.
I'm really excited about it. And I think
probably best first step is to talk a
little bit about what we're gonna be doing.
Yeah. Well, why don't just for anyone who's
not aware of you, you tell us a
little bit about you, and then we'll talk
about the the thing.
Sure.
My name is Lee Briggs. I work at
Pulumi as a developer advocate and formerly in
the engineering team.
I originally from The UK living here in
Seattle in the West Coast Of The US.
So it's good to hear a familiar British
accent.
Alright. Thank you for sharing. Okay. Now enlighten
us. What awesome thing are we doing today?
So we need to provide a bit of
context here, especially if you've never kinda used
Pulumi.
Pulumi is obviously an infrastructure as code tool
that allows you to use what I like
to sell call cheering complete languages. So
instead of using declarative languages like YAML, you
can use imperative languages, but we declare
the imperative language pushes towards a declarative
state, which
is super powerful. And, you know, our customers
love it because it means their front end
engineers who are familiar with TypeScript or their
back end engineers who are maybe writing stuff
in Go, they can use those same languages
that they're using their application life cycle to
actually define infrastructure as well.
You we have a mechanism within Pulumi that
allows you to group
all of the different infrastructure resources that you
are defining into,
what we call a component.
And if you're familiar with stuff like Terraform,
you might have might know of a module
or if you are familiar with the CDK,
you might be familiar with constructs.
Components are our mechanism for,
you know, creating
reusable infrastructure.
And what we usually see is the
companies like to define like best practices in
these components and then share them out within
their organization.
The problem with that is that up until
now, when you've defined your component
and let's say you've written it in our
TypeScript SDK,
you can only really share that with other
people using the TypeScript SDK. So, like, your
ability to kind of like create community modules
or maybe in large enterprises where you have
multiple programming languages and you stack, you've had
to rewrite it multiple times.
And there's been a there's a couple of
really great examples which,
you know, where people have gone to the
trouble of writing their their component SDK
in Go and then TypeScript and then Python.
But the maintenance overhead just kinda gets away
from you really quickly because you happen to
write things in three languages and you might
not know three languages.
So a few weeks ago at our three
point o launch event, we announced what we
call multi language components, which
quite honestly as a technical fee is so
amazing. I don't fully understand like how it's
possible. I mean, I understand the technical
ability of it, but I'm still, like, blown
away that we're basically able to do this.
But what it means is that you can
create a shareable component in one language, and
it will generate the SDK for Pulumi in
all of our supported languages.
So that's what we're gonna be doing today.
We're gonna write a example component
that will allow you to, like, define the
best practices for a deployment. And I think
we decided that the best way to kinda
show this off is
in the Kubernetes world where, like, if you
have an internal Kubernetes platform, you probably wanna
define best practices for
a deployment within your organization, like the the
required number of replicas and then just allow
it to be configurable with just the image
you wanna run.
So we're gonna define that. We're gonna write
it in go, and then we're gonna show
how that that generates an SDK in four
different languages and see an example of deploying
it in TypeScript. And if we have time,
we'll do a Python example as well. So,
it's gonna be a bit of a journey.
I've written like two of these so far,
and I'm still finding some of the, you
know, some intricacies.
But hopefully, we'll be able to kinda show
off what the capabilities of this are,
and we'll get an idea of how powerful
it is.
Awesome.
The timing could could just generally couldn't be
better because I've actually been working on something
that could really leverage this. Like the cluster
API bindings that I've been working on. We're
actually deploying Kubernetes clusters are all all done
in TypeScript just because that's the language that
I prefer to go. But the cloud native
ecosystem is physical developers who wanna work in
go. And if I can expose these bindings
to them through that, that would be amazing.
So I am super excited to see this
work.
So just a final thing, we're gonna be
using the Go SDK today mainly because Go's
ability to build binaries that you can then
reshare is super, super powerful. So I like
to write these in Go. You can write
these components. If you're a Python developer or
a TypeScript developer or a dot net developer,
you can write these components in whatever language
you think is best. But
the the caveat is that, you know, the
the end stream user
will still need to have Node or Python
installed if you write it in those languages.
So Go is really nice for this because
all you have to do is give the
users a binary, and they're off to the
races, basically. Nice.
Alright.
Show me the race.
Okay. So we're I sent you a link
before we started. We're gonna look at the
Pulumi Go boilerplate
provider.
So this is on our GitHub repo.
Yeah. I just gonna leave the Pulumi homepage
up for ten more seconds because I think
it looks so awesome these days with the
the rebranding. You
know? And I I love the rebranding and
shout out to Zach Chase who, like, slaved
away for hours and hours kind of putting
this together and and coding it all up.
I think it looks awesome too. So,
yeah, really, really cool.
So the starting point that we have already
kinda done a little bit of we've got
a template provider here
that
we call the x y z provider.
And what it's basically doing is showing you
an example of creating
a static site in AWS.
But the whole point of this is to
start off with something that
allows us to kind of build something out.
So you already fought this into
Rawkode
Pulumi
dash production app, which we see here.
So the first thing that we need to
do is we need to kinda go through
a bunch of this stuff and just update
the name from x y z into
what we're gonna call production app. So the
first thing I would do is open up
the make file.
And you'll see at the top there the
pack is x y z, so we'll change
that to
production
app.
And then below that in project, you need
to make sure the project is Rawkode rather
than Pulumi.
And then we'll just scroll down and make
sure there's no other missing pieces. I don't
think there is.
And just to quickly go through what this
is doing, this is just a make file
that is going to
generate all of the SDKs once we finish
building this out and then also install them
locally so that we can test it. So
you'll see it's gonna generate
what we call a provider binary, and then
it's also gonna generate all of the different
SDKs. So this is what we're obviously gonna
be using in a few moments.
Next step is we're gonna open up schema
dot JSON.
So this defines the shape of the actual
component itself. So it defines inputs that you're
gonna put into the actual
no. We're gonna do it manual, Paul. We're
gonna do it we're gonna do it so
that people understand what is happening. We're gonna
do it the right way.
So this defines the inputs and the outputs
of the actual component. So this is gonna
allow us to set configurable values for our
users
and also what things that they might want
to use elsewhere. So we're gonna call that
production app and then on line four, we're
gonna switch x y z to production app
as well.
And then instead of static page, we'll call
it deployment, I think. So an an an
a deployment of a production app.
And then the input properties,
we're just gonna clear that map out for
the time being, think is probably the best
way to go ahead, go about this. So
it's actually starting at line six. Sorry. And
I don't wanna kinda, you know, over over
Do we need empty out the required inputs
too?
Yes. We're gonna click. So that's gonna be
an empty array and then
all of the
yeah. All of the required properties.
Okay. So this is just like
JSON declaration
that says this is the thing that we're
creating. These are the inputs that it has,
and then this is the other stuff that
can be layered on the top to customize
it in some way. Is that like like
like a function signature in a weird kind
of way?
Yeah. That's that's probably a good good way
of putting it. Yeah. So I'm also just
gonna clear out this index content here because
that we're we're gonna fill that out in
a few seconds.
So this is gonna show us, like, all
of the things that the users are gonna
be able to configure and then also the
things that they might wanna pass to other
Pulumi resources later.
So
for example, you might wanna generate the deployment
name and all that kind of stuff. We're
not gonna use this today,
but, you know, it's just a a nice
thing to know
later on.
And so the next step, we're gonna define
all of the language dependencies.
And obviously,
for our example, we've got c sharp. We're
gonna in the example, we're using AWS. We're
not gonna use that. We're gonna use Kubernetes.
So on line 14,
we're gonna change that to Kubernetes and then
it's actually three dot star.
Go, we're gonna change the import base path
to our name. So Rawkode Pulumi
production app.
Yeah. Don't forget the Rawkode there. And then
at the end of the x y z
is also production app. Yep.
No JS dependencies update the AWS to Kubernetes
three point
o dot o and then finally Python
again.
And what's great about working at Pulumi is
you get to learn all the different dependency
management systems and how one of how they
all did how work differently.
So you're kinda dealing with so many different
SDKs at a time. You know, you end
up kind of learning the intricacies of setup
dot pie and all that kind of stuff.
So I think
There we go.
Yeah. We
are working on some authoring improvements here. So
we're hoping that we're working on a way
that this will automatically get generated. But for
the time being, it's actually kinda nice being
able to kinda do this manually because you
get to kinda think about a little bit
about what you're doing. But then I don't
get to show off my wonderful,
you know, command line knowledge.
So the the next thing that we're gonna
do yeah. I mean, that that that's probably
at this point, we could just to go
ahead and do that.
The I'm sure we're we're good. Right? Yes.
Okay.
And so then the final thing that we're
doing here, is we're gonna actually update the,
the directory. So if you go back to
your,
yeah. So in the provider directory,
there's go dot mod.
At the top, the module name is gonna
be Rawkode Pulumi production app.
I don't know if you wanna go for
go one sixteen. That definitely works.
And then the Pulumi package and SDK is
gonna be three point three point one.
And you'll need to yeah. You'll need to
yank the there we go. Perfect. Okay.
We'll keep going. And now we're just gonna
update some directory names. So if you go
to your workspace again
in the package directory.
Sorry. No. In the my apologies. In the
command directory.
Yeah.
Rename those
and then rename resource as well.
And then I think there's got some imports
in there as well, so you'll need to
drill down into there.
So this,
this is all fine. What this is doing
is it's reading in that schema and it's
gonna emit the SDK from the schema.
And then
here.
Looks like a c m s oh, there
we go. There we go.
I'm sure we've missed one of these, but
we'll we'll figure it out. And then don't
forget the online 20 as well. Don't forget
the Rawkode for Pulumi
in the that's it. Yeah. And the import
name as well.
Kinda manual at the moment. You know, we
we we are working on the author and
experience for sure.
So anything in the examples or SDK is
gonna be fine.
All of the stuff that we're really looking
for is in the provider thing here. So
we are gonna be looking at the provider
package in a moment.
So what I would recommend is just blowing
away the SDK directory because we're gonna regenerate
that every single time. What about the example
directory?
And that as well. Yeah. That's probably easier.
You sure?
Yes.
We're not they we're not gonna be using
that just yet. I promise.
Alright. We could ignore the read me.
So that means we got just a provider
one now. So let's jump back. Yeah. So
yep.
It's in command, I think,
in the provider command. Sorry. The there's there's
two command directories. There's command and then provider
command.
Oh, there we have provider package.
Alright.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah. There is one. Production
app. Question after deployment. Right?
That's right. Yeah.
And that's it. So,
what we're gonna do now is we're gonna
rename the static page. Go into into productionapp.co.
I'll
gonna rename that. I I I like to
call it deployment.co because that's what we're be
And then if we open that up
okay. So this is where we're actually gonna
do all of the logic that we're actually
going to kind of do use to create
our provider. So currently, we're using the AWS
provider. We can completely remove,
line
18,
and just do because we because the the
the Kubernetes provider's laid out slightly differently.
And you, you're way ahead of me already.
So you
Yeah. But I to make you to me
no.
To me, that actually
shows that it's relatively intuitive. So yes. So
we're gonna create a deployment with deployment arcs.
We haven't decided that we're gonna have index
content yet, so let's get rid of all
of that. And then line twenty nine and
twenty and 30, we can get rid of
those because those are gonna be the actual
outputs that we're gonna create. We're not gonna
do new static page. We're gonna do new
deployment.
Okay. So I should just rename it rather
than delete it? Yeah. Just rename it. Yeah.
And that takes deployment args on line 32.
And then we also redirect to deployment args
there.
And then 37.
It's not it's just a component is a
new in yeah.
And then here you can see where where
we register our component. That will be production
app
index
deployment.
There we go.
We're not gonna be creating a bucket, we
can get rid of that.
And you can see that this is all
just gonna be creating leave that leave that.
We're gonna need that in a few moments.
So what you wanna be removing
and I can probably jump in here and
help. I'm making you do all the work.
Yeah. Try to step back and relax. Alright.
You've already done it.
So then the final thing that we're gonna
remove is this register resource output is gonna
be the thing that we're gonna export in
our production app. We're not gonna export anything.
So this can be just an empty Pulumi
map. So lines forty four and forty five
can can go.
Beautiful. Okay. So what is that? Like five
minutes and we have bootstrapped our provider and
we're ready to actually,
add some stuff to this now to actually
make it useful. So we need to do
a few imports.
What we'll need to a question just now?
Absolutely.
Alright.
We got a we Paul has answered it
in the comments, but let's get Andreas a
good answer. So
no, no offense, Paul. I love you really.
But Andrea is asking,
does that mean Oh, that went away fast.
Stay.
Does that mean that consuming several public components
might require to have node and Python available
even if the stack itself is defined and
go lang. So you're basically generating API stubs.
I don't know why that keeps disappearing.
Yes, basically. So like the language that you're
actually using, like if you're consuming this component
in Python, are you consuming this this component
in TypeScript, you'll need those available to actually
kind of create the the infrastructure.
Because we're writing this in Go,
you'll need to have the also the actual
Pulumi binary locally installed as well. And we'll
generate that and put it in the path.
But you like, because we're defining it in
Go, if you wanna consume this in TypeScript,
you will not need Python as an example.
Right? So this is relatively common for some
of our larger customers who have, like, clean
laptops and they're like, we want this specific
version of this specific,
you know,
language.
You'll only need the language you're consuming it
in. You don't need all of Pulumi supported
languages installed to use this because we're writing
it in Go.
Okay.
So hopefully that answers the question.
Okay. So what we're gonna do now is
we're gonna use the Kubernetes SDK
to actually define a
a namespace,
a deployment, and a service. This is just
a hypothetical
production app. So I'm gonna copy these for
you
into
the dependencies
so that you I don't have to tell
you to type them all out.
So these are all of the different types
of dependencies. If you scroll up to where
the dependencies are, we're gonna be using apps
v one. If you are familiar with Kubernetes,
this will look pretty familiar. It's basically just
the Kubernetes API.
And we're gonna use apps v one, call
v one, which is where the namespaces are,
and meta v one for all the different
types and stuff.
So I've imported those for us.
The next thing that we're going to do
is go back down to our new deployment.
Well, if we scroll down a little bit.
Yep. And this is just where we're gonna
start to actually define all of the stuff
that we want. So what I like to
do here is like set up some labels
that we're gonna pass to all of these
resources because it kinda shows that you don't
have to kinda repeat yourself.
So
below where the arguments is on line 39
just to create a new variable labels.
And we're gonna do Pulumi
dot string map.
And we're gonna add some labels
of
app.
So the actual
It these don't actually need to be a
Pulumi dot string. So it's just a,
app.kubernetes.i0
forward slash app is what I like to
call that label.
Sorry. I'm not I'm not doing a great
job of
yeah.
And then the this value is a Pulumi
dot string. But what we're actually gonna do
is just pass the name from the actual
deployment. So we'll do Pulumi dot string
name, and that comes from
here.
And I don't know if you can see
me highlighting in the Versus code because I've
turned the livestream off, but cool. So then
that's gonna come from there. And then also
we're gonna do app dot production.
And, again, this is just a nice label
to pass through to everything dot instance
for slash name
Pulumi
dot string
name. Oh,
apparently, I have not learned to type this
morning.
So then we could just pass these to
all the different different, resources that we're gonna
create, which is nice and simple.
Next thing we're gonna do is we're gonna
create a namespace
error.
And this is where we start to use
our
dependencies.
And I think you're gonna have to go
get them so that we get all of
the type hints.
Alright. Let's comment now so it's happy at
least.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm in the wrong directory. Right? So
that was a Yes. It's a provider. It's
in the provider directory.
And, yeah, we've got a go mod. Uh-oh.
Okay.
Interesting.
There we go. I never understand go mode.
I just keep typing commands until something works.
I
think you've just described my whole career.
So then we should hopefully get the type
hints now. So if we and
I'll let you. Yeah. And so then it
will be New
namespace. Yeah.
That takes the first argument is the context
or CTX. So that's the Pulumi context.
And then All of these take the
yep. Then the name and then it's an
as it's pointed to call v one
and
ampersand. Sorry. Call v one
dot namespace args.
Like so.
Yep.
Then we need to specify some metadata. So
yep. Let's populate that and that takes an
meta v one
object meta args,
and then we'll put the name,
I think it's capital n,
Pulumi
dot string name.
And then the labels obviously can come from
the actual labels variable.
I've forgotten how to go. I've been writing
Rust all week.
Bear with me. Yeah. You've gone you've gone
full hipster then.
What is missing here? Oh, why have I
got two?
That'll be it.
And there's another one at the end there.
There you go.
Okay.
So then we're doing go, so we need
to check the error.
Of course.
What I like to do here is I
like to so this object returns two things.
It returns a deployment and it returns an
error. So we're just gonna return nil.
And then what I like to do is
actually return a little bit more helpful error.
So I do format dot error f.
Sorry. It looks a little bit like yeah.
There we are.
Error creating namespace
colon
percent v. I do percent v because it's
nice.
And
then the actual error.
And that and I think we'll need to
import format as well. Yeah. Yeah. It looks
like it's Versus code. We should be good.
So that would create our namespace for us.
Let's create our deployment.
We will use the namespace later, but for
this the deployment, we're not actually gonna use
the variables. So we're gonna do empty variables.
So
error
equals
and it's just equals. Yeah.
I'll let you take over from here. Oh,
alright. So we want a core v one.
It's v one because it's a deployment
rather than core v one.
What did we import?
Oh, it's it's yanked our definition.
Let me let me grab It is apps
v one. Right? Yeah. It is. But it's
actually the import has disappeared because I'm guessing
we're not using it. So
I've added it back at the top there.
Dot new deployment. Yep. And then of course
that takes a context,
a name,
and then and apps v one
deployment args.
And, like, if you're if you're familiar with
Go, this all starts to seem a bit,
familiar after a while. Like,
but the deployment object is a little bit
more complicated so that
I think you've missed a I think you've
added an erroneous space there
on 56.
Let me get rid of that for you.
So then that takes metadata as well.
So we'll start with the metadata
in caps,
and it's object meta v one object meta
rags.
I think you need a pointer. So let
me add that for you. Okay.
And then she we're gonna get the we're
gonna grab the namespace that this deployment deploys
in
from the namespace variable.
And this is Pulumi's outputs at work. So
it will be
namespace,
and you can kind of finish it off
from there, dot metadata.
So it looks like this. So it's metadata
dot
a You want the name of it, of
course, not the object. And then you actually
need to get the element as well. So
it like that.
So if you're not familiar with Pulumi,
this is the way that we create dependencies
between two different objects. So we're getting what
we call the output, the the name from
this namespace. We're getting that output and we're
passing it to a new resource.
This allows Pulumi to know that it needs
to create the namespace first and then create
the deployment second.
And this is how we're able to use
imperative languages and create this dependency graph,
which is super powerful.
So then we're gonna define the spec,
and this would be
and apps v one
dot
deployment
spec args.
And this is where,
the ability to do,
you know, strongly type languages comes really handy
because
you,
you know, you're getting all of the like,
it it's really hard. It's surprisingly hard to
make a mistake here,
because
it's telling us what it needs.
Label select to ask.
Match labels
is the
labels. And you're probably understanding why I set
up those
those very the the variable now because, like,
you can obviously make mistakes there.
And then we want replicas.
And this is kinda where
I like to point out that because we
ask the people authoring this SDK are the
experts,
we want this to be a hypothetical production
application. And we know that
a production application is not one replica. Right?
Like, we know that. We don't wanna make
this configurable.
So let's hard code it so that all
of the people consuming this particular,
component,
they're always going to have a highly available
application. So we'll make replicas of three, and
we're not gonna let them actually, you know,
let our consumers modify this,
if that makes sense. Obviously,
we are going to be adding arguments to
this at some point, but, like, I guess
the point I'm trying to get across here
is, like, when we're defining these components, the
the my thought process is that you only
should
have input arguments that you actually want your
users to be able to to modify and
consume.
Okay. So we're gonna do a template
and call v one
pod template args.
More metadata because Kubernetes loves its metadata.
Object meta as
labels,
and then the spec for the actual pod.
Pod spec.
And
this is where we're actually gonna be defining
the container.
And this I think
is
let's see if this is correct. Pod spec
arcs. Yep. Containers.
That takes an array
of containers.
So I'm calling one container.
And this live share is really hard.
It's just that it's just that little delay,
from, like, doing things locally is,
an interesting
I think all viewing one container
array.
And the reason that we have to do
these, special types with Pulumi,
is because these values are like, this is
not a a standard kind of slice,
and it's because these values are, like, computed.
So we don't know them upfront.
Call v one container args.
And I'm gonna let you this is your
show, so I'm gonna let you finish round
this one out.
So we're gonna take the name of the
actual container will be Pulumi dot string.
And let's hard code this for now,
the image. So what we'll do is we'll
hard code the
we'll make that name. Our main is fine.
Yeah. NGINX is fine.
Ports.
That takes a
and call v one. Let me just check.
Yeah. Core one container port and put array.
So
And call v one
container port array.
And then and call v one
container
port axe.
And container port,
let's call that 80, I guess.
Pulumi dot int 80. Yeah.
Okay. And then there's one. There we go.
So this is your deployment and your
and your
namespace.
Final thing is the service.
If you
hopefully, the the cluster that you set up
can support low balance of services.
I assume it can.
Should be alright.
We'll give it a we'll give it a
try.
So we're gonna define a service,
and we're not gonna use this. So
equals
call v one new service.
And, of course, that takes a context. It
takes a name,
and then it's an call v one service
r. Oh.
Metadata, of course. Of course.
And I think we can just Copy that,
I think. Yeah. Make our lives a little
easier and copy this. You know?
It's just occurring to me that when we
what we could have done is set up
a,
a variable for that, but
this is go. It likes to be the
verbose, of course.
Ports
and call v one service
port array.
Got a a way for Mark. Hey, Mark.
Thanks for joining.
And call v one
service
part.
Part
is Pulumi
dot int 80. And I always forget this
is the actual part that the load balancer
listens on. So target port is Pulumi dot
n 80 as well.
I think
oh, we need a type as well. Yes.
Right now, that's just gonna be a cluster
IP service, which is okay.
Let me not string.
We can always remove this if that's this
doesn't work. Because we're just showing how it
doesn't have to be. It doesn't actually have
to be a production ready application.
So this is a cluster API cluster running
bare metal on Equinix metal running metal LB,
the Equinix metal CCM.
I mean, there's a whole bunch of stuff
here that's configured.
I'm sure I got it all right and
the load balancer will work, but we'll see.
Well, if it's got my LLB, it should
work. Right?
And we have a problem here
and I'm not sure.
Yeah. It was just a comma. I fixed
it.
I'm still getting an error on line one
or two. Maybe my live share is not
updating. It makes it alright.
Okay. Well, we'll see how it works. So
this is this is defined all of our
infrastructure. Right? So we could generate this SDK
and then we could actually consume it, but
it's not really very usable. Right? Because
we're obviously gonna wanna deploy more than just
NGINX.
Right? So
here is where we start to kind of
set up some of the parts that allow
us to,
you know, allow us to make it configurable.
So we're gonna scroll all the way back
up
to our production app arcs.
Sorry. Our deployment arcs.
Yep. And this is where we're gonna actually
start to add the the two things that
I can think of that we need to
allow to be configurable is the image.
So what part of the struct will create
an image,
and we'll do and this is a type
of Pulumi dot string input.
And I think your colon has vanished at
the end there.
And then we also need to put a
a type on this. So the way this
looks is,
and I'll fill this in so that we
can,
so this is
oops. Oh, man.
Versus code is giving me a nightmare.
So what we need to do is add
very similar to what we would do with
JSON. We need to do
something like
this. So that just will that means that
when we read the the schema in, this
is the value that it's gonna read from
that schema dot JSON. So we're gonna need
to update that in a few moments.
And then the other argument that we're gonna
want is the port. So let's
we'll make configurable to our users.
Pulumi dot int input.
Yep. Pulumi.
There we go.
And so now we can actually
pass this stuff to our deployment as well.
So if we scroll back to our deployment
I'm worried that go format hasn't kicked in.
That normally means that we have an error.
Yeah. We've got
I know we asked a break point.
Do have a break point? It'll I did
not add a break point. I don't even
know what they are.
Right. Okay. I'll assume it's fine. I don't
see any any When
this builds, it'll tell us what it'll tell
us what the problem is. Oh, no. Now
I've got an error on that line. Okay.
I didn't have that error there. So we're
missing a comma somewhere.
We're missing the closed bracket, I think. Alright.
There we go.
Hang on. Let me Did it format the
top? I did. Okay. We're good.
We're good. See, look, this is x. This
is what this is programming at work.
It's weird that I justify whether my code
is gonna work or not, whether the format
kicks in or not. The format doesn't kick
kick in, I know that I've broken something.
So now we're actually gonna pass those arguments
to our
to our deployment. So if you scroll back
down to
where we defined it defined NGINX,
we can change that image
to args dot
image.
And then the container port here on 79,
we can do args dot port.
Easy. So
now we need to update the schema so
that we can actually tell Pulumi
that these are required when we generate the
SDK. So if we go back to our
schema
Oh, yep. That that's right. The JSON.
Yeah. So this is where these input properties
come in.
And so what this needs to look like
and I need to actually look at a
reference example here because we're still I'm just
making Yes.
No. No. You're you're basically right. But we
they need to be lower case because that's
what's on the actual thing.
And then here is where we define a
map of properties. So we're gonna do image.
We need to define what the type is
because, obviously, we generate strongly typed libraries. So
we do string
like so. And then we get to add
a description for the type hints.
And, hopefully, you can see, like, this is
this is what are gonna allow our users
to get a little bit more information when
they're using this. So the
the image to deploy
in your production
ready
application,
And it's JSON, so it doesn't want a
comma there. And then port
type is
integer
description.
The part your
application
listens
on in your
Docker.
It's not technically Docker anymore, so we'll just
go, in your image. Container image. Yeah.
Container image. Yeah. That makes sense.
So these are the things that are gonna
define what our input types are. This properties
thing here, we're not gonna use this today,
but this properties
is the thing that will allow you to
say
if you've used Pulumi before, like, all the
outputs that we have, like, you can also
define outputs. So
if we wanted to, we could say, like,
return the load balancer that has been created
that you might wanna use in different things.
We're not gonna do that, in this particular
case because it's supposed to be a relatively
simple example.
So I think I think that's everything,
but we'll find out when we start to
do some of the fun generation stuff. So
if you go back to your terminal
Can can we just summarize what we've what
we've done there? I'll summarize it to you
and you can tell me if I got
anything incorrect.
Sounds good.
Alright. So
we are using the Pulumi component provider GoBoilerPlate
repository. This can be used as a template
to
provide the base for any multi language Pulumi
component.
Yes. What we did there was just really
go through and do some rudimentary changes. We
were modifying the x y z, which is
the example name for the component to be
our production app, and then we modified the
static page, which is just one of the
resources that the boilerplate or provider starts with,
and we've modified that to consume the Kubernetes
API provider deployment
and a service.
And we've exposed through this little JSON schema
style document, the ability to
understand what input properties there are as well
as which ones are required,
And then we've just done a little bit
of glue inside of the the Go code
to actually create those resources.
Yes. That's exactly what we've done. That's exactly
what we've done. And the process is exactly
the same for
all of the different languages. If you wanna
write one of these in Python,
you're basically gonna do the same thing. You're
gonna define a schema that looks that the
you know, if you are familiar with, like,
TypeScript and you basically, I think of them
as interfaces.
So this schema is the interface that, like,
the the consumable interface for all of the
different, like the shape of this thing that
we're gonna do to find.
As our boiler plate think it's t s.
It's t s not not TypeScript.
Yeah. So is there a boiler plate for
all the supported languages in Pulumi then that
people can just go and use as a
template and get started with their language of
choice. Right? Okay. I think the only one
missing right now is .net. I think we've
got that that on the way. But Python
p we got a p y. And if
you go and look at the provider in
the TypeScript example,
you'll see that, like, inside here,
this is like the go binary. So if
you go into command
we're still using the same go binaries to
generate all of this stuff, but if you
come back up to the root level.
Yep.
I'm actually, like, completely blanking on where the
actual TypeScript code is here. Let me just
have a look.
I looked at the Python one before we
started. Oh, there's TypeScript in here. It's under
provider command resource. And then it was There
we go. Yeah. We got some TypeScript here.
So you should see setting it's doing very
similar things. It's gonna read the the bunch
of different stuff and then the actual static
page is defined there.
And so again, like, the the only caveat
with this is that
your downstream users will still need to have
TypeScript on node installed.
So as part of your as part of
your we are looking at some examples like
you can embed these TypeScript files into
you know, you can bundle these up as
TypeScript binaries and all that kind of stuff.
We're looking at different ways to make that
easier.
But it's essentially your downstream users because this
is obviously gonna invoke this Pulumi program. You'll
still need to have TypeScript installed.
Yeah. I wonder if you could just embed
like a node runtime. I think there is
a couple of go versions into into binary.
Of course, the size of that may be
a little bit ridiculous at that point. We
have our hackathon coming up. I'm gonna come
up with some wild and crazy ideas for
things we can do here, hopefully.
And then there's the Python one as well.
So if you do p y dash boiler
p y dash boilerplate.
Again, in provider.
I don't think I've ever looked at a
hyphen.
So the actual code is in x y
v provider at the top there. Alright.
And then static page at the bottom. I
have strong opinions about Python, which I won't
share here because I may get I may
get
piled on on Twitter.
But, yeah, like, if you wanna write it
in Python, then go nuts. Well, that that's
the joy, right, of of why we wanna
use Pulumi over any other tools like this.
Is that flexibility
to stick to the languages, run times, and
tool chains that I'm already familiar with? Like,
I don't have to go and learn anything
new. So, you know, whatever your poison is,
go for it.
My my my perspective as well is the,
you know,
application developers especially like they're
a lot of cases, they're they're kinda getting
exposed to cloud environments and cloud engineering environments.
That's already super confusing. And then when you
add a new kind of like declarative YAML
document on top of it that they might
not understand,
you know, it's it's a massive learning curve.
Like imagine
somebody
especially I always kind of compare it to
as infrastructure engineer. Imagine if somebody told me
that I had to learn front end and
back end at the same time. Like,
you're just throwing things at me that I
don't really understand.
So it's it's a it's like
my perspective has always been using these familiar
languages is a really nice way to kind
of gradually introduce people to new concepts, but
using something that they already know. It's it's
a much better way of learning in my
experience. Oh, yeah. Definitely.
Alrighty. So I think we should generate this.
Now let's generate this. So let's go to
a terminal
and we should be able to do and
I need to remember the make it's actually
we do we use the make file. Yeah.
So we need to first run make generate,
which will generate all of our SDKs and
it's also gonna tell us if there's any
problems.
Can I just can I just go for
it? Let's go for it. Yeah.
I'm in the wrong directory.
You're you're in the wrong directory.
Alright. No. I'm not feeling as brief anymore,
I'm just gonna do generate.
I've lost my confidence. This
is kinda this will show you what's actually
happening here. We're running go run to actually
generate the we're passing the schema in,
and it's allowing us to generate the Go
SDK, and it's gonna generate the TypeScript test
again, all that kind of stuff.
It's taking longer than I expected.
Excellent. We have an error. This is what
we love to see. So let's have a
look
at what we've done wrong here.
An assertion has failed.
Oh, this is a lovely error.
We've obviously made a mistake. So if if,
it it's happening in the SDK
portion.
I'm just gonna look the code real quick.
I'm sorry. You can say I got it
wrong. I won't be offended.
There must be a problem in the
schema itself.
We have an error here. Yeah. Haven't updated
any of this, actually. We haven't updated anything
below here.
And in fact Did we forget some
do we forget something? Let me look at
my example that I wrote of three weeks
ago.
And Paul Stack says the token is incorrect.
The token is incorrect.
Gonna give us a bit more of a
bit more help here, Paul.
I'm half tempted to just bring him in
here at this point.
Yeah. Come on, Paul. Show us what's wrong.
Which token?
Does he see that from the error message?
Let's see.
We got main dot go.
The token is incorrect. I'm gonna
Maybe something in the schema. I think the
code looks alright and it's not
I think it was something in the schema
as well. Yeah. Is it did we get
the token wrong
production app index?
Paul asks, where is our declaration of the
type?
Are you being cryptic
on on purpose? I I we both know
Paul well enough to know that he probably
is.
Okay. So where is our declaration of the
type? Declaration of the type? Alright. Let's turn
this into crystal me style deployment.
Start the fence,
please.
This is our
declaration of what a deployment is. Are we
missing anything in a struct?
Nope. That so that struct will output the
that that would have usually that would have
the outputs.
So, no, that that should be absolutely fine.
Okay. We're getting some more hints from our
a good friend here who suggest that we
open schema dot JSON. We take a look
at the resources.
What is the first item?
It is
what I expect it to be, to be
fair.
Yeah. Is component true, input properties.
I actually have a working version of this
as well and it looks exactly the same.
So we've missed something.
Can
you rerun the make again? I wanna take
a look another look at the error.
Yeah. I'll send Paul a link. He can
just jump in for five minutes if he
wants.
So this is in command
production app provider.
Alright.
Command.
I love it when we get just random
random extra guests.
Well, until he learns how to articulate his
thoughts properly through the chat system in order
for the other that we are suffering in
a live stream.
Yeah.
Said So what I think he's what I
think he's talking about if you go back
to the
if you go back to the Versus Code,
I'm in
main provider.
So if you look here
And January resource
one. No. That was January.
So this is where the error is coming
from on line 24 production app, but it
looks right to me.
Or maybe that should be deployment.
I think that might be no. That's the
provider name.
Interesting.
This is the full this is the great
thing about using brand new stuff,
when you
are in a livestream. I'm I'm pretty confident
we'll get this working.
Alright. Well, PR is asking, did we remember
to sacrifice our first born to the demo
gods? I mean, no.
I knew I've got something.
Didn't quite
Okay. Sorry. What
was your hypothesis there? So let's look at
this error message. I'd like to understand
what assertions is the generator doing here against
our schema and our code.
So it's looking at the actual provider name
at the top of the schema dot JSON.
Which is our production app here?
Yeah. My I think what what I'd like
to try is let's try changing,
if you go back to index here?
That's just like the actual place in the
Pulumi resource model where it lives. That's the
only thing that it's not,
that is that I know that is definitely
shouldn't be changed.
I think we should try calling it deployment,
like the actual token name in the in
the previous
file. So
in the yeah. Let's try changing that to
deployment,
on '24.
Yeah. Let's give that a try. Well, this
is no complaining about
Pulumi schema.
That's because of the that's because it doesn't
exist yet. The the
it will generate a schema dot go file
when this step works. Alright. Okay.
It seems to be the same.
What
okay. Like, my my idea here.
Hey, Paul.
Hey, folks.
So, Leo, I think the issue is that
your import bay bay bay base pass may
not be correct in your Pulumi schema.
It's trying to tokenize what's coming out
of,
further down that that list, and it's it
doesn't seem as though it's correct.
Oh, I see what you're saying. Okay. So
you're saying that line 31
on this schema
Yes. You think that the that should be
deployment at the end there, so lowercase deployment?
So Not necessarily
deployment.
It needs to be the name of the
actual SDK that's that you're trying to generate.
So, like, for example, for me, I my
input base path would be github.com/stack72/PulumiGCPcloudrunglobal/SDK/go/GCPcloudrunglobal.
So it it all depends on what you're
actually trying to generate at the back end.
Yeah. I think I think he's right. That
needs to be deployment. Give that another try.
I think I think that's probably
The funny thing is Lee hates it if
I'm right. I
do hate it if you're right. Absolutely.
So what I'm gonna recommend here is I'm
gonna get this closer to the to the
version that we actually had working. So I'm
gonna change this to production app and then
because, you know, because I knew this was
gonna I knew this was gonna happen.
If you
what I had this was as production app,
app ads,
production app, because these are all just structs
at the end of the day.
Let me look at my example.
New
Which file are you modifying just now?
I am in
the actual provider that we created. So although
it's it's bouncing me around a little bit.
So I'm gonna do new
production app.
Production
app.
Is really great because we can feed this
back to,
the team as like like, this error message
is just not very helpful. So we'd obviously
need to open an issue for that, make
sure that we get that right. So this
is what I when I when I ran
through this yesterday to make sure that this
was actually gonna work,
I actually called this production app ARG rather
than production app and deployment. And again, it's
just structs, but I think we've missed a
token somewhere like Paul said.
So let's give that another try and see
what happens.
Oh, wait. I know. Oh, I know. I've
just figured out what it is.
I know exactly what it is.
So if you see where I am right
now Yeah. I'm following you. So
this is the problem. If you scroll down,
you still got a reference to static pay
we still got a reference to static page
ARGs here. So this should be
we've changed it. That should be production app
ARGs, and then this needs to be
new production.
Yeah. Line 29 has a static page on
it too.
29.
Construct.
Oh, no. Construct deployment is still Construct it
just
yeah. Just rename that function to construct deployment.
Alright. There we go. There we go.
That, I think, is what the problem was.
That does not look correct.
Still getting an error.
Yeah. Well, probably we've probably messed yeah. We've
messed one change in back. So deployment dot
goal lane 58 has that deployment RX on
it.
Oh, no. That's no. That's correct.
Because that's the actual
Oh, yeah. That's the actual deployment.
Yes.
What about this one here, Lane 30 9
at the end? Looks wrong. Yeah. That looks
like that's like it should be production app
because it's gonna return an instance of a
production app. So let's try that again.
No. Come
on.
Yeah. Let's look for red squiggles.
Oh, there's a big one.
So we can't register component resource because
there's no new deployment.
This
is a production app.
And I'm I'm remembering now the exhibit the
reason why I call this production app in
rather than deployment is so that I could
search for errors,
because we're using the Kubernetes SDK and deployment
and it returned a bunch of stuff. So
that should be a production app.
Alright. There you go. No more red.
Come on. We could do this.
I mean, I don't have any confidence in
me, but I know you two will get
it.
Let's see. Let's use the s code here.
It's normally quite good at telling us where
the reds are. Everything looks alright. So
as the code's not complaining and goes language
server's happy,
maybe now it's a schema thing.
Maybe. I'm also gonna can you rename deployment.
Code to production app with a capital a
just to make sure that it's like
So After all this, it will be it'll
be it'll be a yes. So just rename
that to production app
with a capital a. There we go.
And let's take a final look at the
scuba dot JSON.
Yeah. This still has deployment here.
So that needs to be deployment. That's the
actual,
that's the resource that's gonna be generated. So
that's that's okay.
I'm just going through this line by line
at the moment. Required inputs.
Nah. Yeah. No. That's right.
I'm gonna try it.
I believe in you.
Yep. I'm wrong.
Can you do me a favor? Can you
git git commit what we have?
And
like I have a working instance of this
and so I'm gonna start copying code over
to see what we've missed.
Oh, yeah. Of course. Yeah. Go for it.
So
just get add everything?
Yeah. Get add. Just get just do an
initial commit.
YOLO and
push.
Did I clone my fork?
Yeah.
Did I?
Well, that's not gonna work.
Yeah. I don't think you need to push
it. Just having it locally is probably good
enough. Alright. I thought you wanted to maybe
No. No. No. I'm just I'm gonna do
a git diff when we when I start
copying stuff over.
Oh, yeah. Cool. Basically. Makes sense. So
this is my
schema dot JSON, and the only difference here
is that I added an output. So I'm
gonna save that. Mhmm. And if you go
git diff
now to see what the differences are.
Did you save it?
Oh, no. I didn't. Alright.
So the description's changed.
Image reports the other way around, but other
than that, there's
no gold definition anymore.
It's a little bit further down. Alright. There
we are. So that's so you can see
the package name and the import base path
are obviously set to things that I would
have.
If you generate that, see what happens. It's
probably gonna fail because the import's wrong.
Nope. It works.
So
what? What's different here?
So the descriptions, the input property ordering,
none of that can matter. Right? The output
URL and a fussed about
I don't think that's important.
So it must be just So that
was I obviously didn't get a chance to
actually get this done last night, but the
idea here is that this production app will
output a URL from our load balancer.
And so eventually, we'll get to the point
where we can update this. So I would
recommend here is let's update the import base
path to actually remove my name and do
a Rawkode instead of my GitHub username Jack
Storm and then rerun it. But
now that we have this in Git, I
can go and have a look and see
what was different, basically.
So let's rerun that.
That works.
Must just have been a typo. See, this
is the problem. Like, what we're actually hoping
to do is actually emit this JSON scheme
rather than build it manually so you can't
make these mistakes. I think this is a
great example of, like, why
using these kind of, like, untyped documents can
be so difficult. The only part of this
that we had trouble with is this untyped
part.
So let's also remove,
the properties and required outputs,
because we're not gonna use those. So if
we open up our,
so that property sees an empty map
and then require yeah. And then so we
should be able to rerun that.
No. It's good. Oh, Paul left us.
Thanks for saying bye. See you later, Paul.
Thanks for your help. Okay.
Yeah. No. We appreciate it. So that's the
so that's the schema that's generated. So now
we should be able to do make build
as well.
So what this is gonna do is it's
gonna, sorry. Go ahead. I just was I
I liked what you were saying there as
I was trying to type and and kinda
think at the same time. But, like, the
schema can be inferred from the canonical implementation,
and you're working on generating the schema from,
like, the ghost structs or the type script.
Yes. Okay. Awesome. That's exactly what you said.
Like, so the ghost that part of the
reason why we got that Pulumi definition on
the ghost structure is we should we we
are working on kinda generating the schema manually.
I mean, I guess you could implement a
validator on the scheme as well, but, like,
I think it's kinda telling that the one
part of this that we had to have
handwrite basically without any type hints caused a
bunch of problems.
And it's still not clear what that problem
was. I hope you're gonna git commit this
so I can go back and look at
it later.
Yeah. I'll push it up. Don't worry.
So just to talk about what's actually happening
here.
So you obviously don't have dot net installed.
So let's just update the make file and
not generate the dot net part.
K. So on build, we do not want
dot net SDK.
And we don't wanna install it either. So
if you look at the make make file
as well while that's running, we'll do remove
install.net
Yep.
So, yeah, again, to just talk a lot
a little bit while what's happening here. Like,
what this is doing is it's building us
a binary that we will then distribute to
our users.
Usually, you would install this with Pulumi plug
in install,
and that will get easy need either needs
to be in your Pulumi directory or in
the actual path of your,
you know, on your machine. So it's doing
a go, it's doing a go build,
and it's actually generating the schema. If you
look after the r and minus r f,
it's gonna clear out your bin directory.
It's gonna generate the actual schema, which ends
up being a go file, which is why
we were getting that error early for Pulumi
schema.
And then it's gonna build a binary
that you would distribute. And now here is
the point where it's gonna generate all the
different SDKs. So the Python and Node JS
SDKs.
So are these like, you know, when I
you know, say I wanted to ship this
now, like, I'm just pushing the code to
get hub and go developers can import it
from that source for TypeScript. And my publishing
to NPM for Python, I'm publishing to pipeline.
Right. Okay. That's exactly it. Yeah. So you
would need to jet you would need to
push the packages to all of your respective
package managers. You also need to distribute a
binary to the users.
And we are working right now on automatically
generating
automatically being able to grab that binary
from
when you do the NPM install or the
PIP install.
This already happens with Pulumi,
for all of our kind of, like, multi
language providers.
When you do NPM install at Pulumi Kubernetes,
it pulls down the binary for you. And
so you'll be able to do,
you know, be able to do the same
process basically.
These actually end up looking just like those
by those, like, Pulumi providers.
So it's a binary and then an SDK.
I see you running in the install command
now. So
this should create a Yarn linkable package for
us that we can then use in our
example.
Alright. So does that mean we wanna create
a Pulumi TypeScript application now to be able
to consume?
I generally put in an example so that
everybody can see what it looks like. So
I'll do make make directory examples and then
TypeScript.
Okay.
New directory
example
TypeScript. And we wanna add Pulumi new in
this?
Yes.
K. Example.
TypeScript.
Pulumi new.
Just TypeScript. I just do put I just
do Pulumi new TypeScript here.
Yeah. That should work.
Let's see how that installs there. Okay. That's
done.
So now you should be able to run
Yarnlink.
And the reason that I told you to
update so obviously, you wanna put you can't
publish this to the app Pulumiorg. So now
you would publish this to at Rawkode in
NPM.
So we can Yarnlink that package inside that
example.
Yep.
Fighter? No.
No. You just the just your own link
is fine. It did it it's already in
like, the install make,
already did that.
Right. And so then we can open up
that example,
that TypeScript example.
Import all.
Yarn link is magic. Don't pretend to try
and understand understand it.
At Rawkode.
Wow.
And then you should be able to do
a const Rawkode.
Yeah.
Equals new.
It's
a it's a class. Right? Yeah.
And then we also need a name, so
let's just call this example.
Yeah. So name and then args.
So example,
args.
I don't think they're all complete. It's quite
kicked in there yet, but we know that
it's a
image.
And it's cap, I think. Yeah.
So then image which set in NGINX.
I'm gonna use the Yarn as well first.
It's because you're using Rawkode too many times.
So you need to do
if you go back to your Oh, yeah.
So const.
There we go. Yeah. I wonder if that
fixes the yeah. There we go. Okay. So
deploy engine x. We've got a report.
So we should be able to Pulumi up
this if you've got your Kubernetes.
And again, this is a this is a
component resource. So you could pass providers to
this if you wanted to. This is just
a standard Pulumi application.
Should be able to do Pulumi up. I
do have a context
set. There's no pods running. We run a
Pulumi up.
Oh, TypeScript.
Wanted to just wanted to make you swear
a bit, Avatar. Hey. Oh, I'm on. I
was panicking then.
Alright. So help me understand what this is
actually doing. Right? We have linked to the
Yarn generated SDK,
which is generating types so that TypeScript is
aware of what we have available to us.
But as it as it calling out to
a gold binary, right, to do the actual
deployment and the service and such. I am
not the person to explain this, but I'm
gonna have my very very best. Right?
So what this is doing
is it generates all of the actual, like,
SDK and then just this registers
inside the actual Pulumi engine.
So that's what the binary is doing is
it basically takes the TypeScript,
converts it into like a a schema implementation,
and then the Pulumi engine does all of
the work.
So that's why it's really useful to write
these in Go because you can just distribute
that binary and it can call the go
straight to the Pulumi engine.
This is
really, really kind of, like,
deep technology,
and I'm not gonna profess to understand
quite how it works at its at its
full level. And I even asked before I
came on. Was like, somebody's gonna try and
explain how this works to me because it
is it's literal magic. Like, we've written a
program in one,
you know, we've written something in one language
and we are able to consume it in
another language. It's just wild to me.
And this will work with Python. It will
work with Go.
We've obviously made a mistake without Kubernetes definition
rather than the actual Pulumi program.
So if you do if you do a
new terminal, new qctl,
it's probably something silly.
Kubectl
get
namespace?
I don't know. Just pick up my
yeah.
It has created the namespace.
Kubectl get p o minus
yeah.
Oh, wait. Why am I doing Get get
get get
But I think the service has been created.
It's got a low it's actually got an
IP, a load balancer IP, and stuff like
that, but it's never gonna find any pods
because, yeah, we've missed something in the spec.
And we can wait for this to time
out and see the error. I don't know
if I'll get it either. Minutes. It's ten
minutes, so it takes a little while. Right.
So what I would do is
control c out of that and then Pulumi
destroy.
Here we are. There we are. Required value
for the container port.
Or no.
It looks like our actual types aren't coming
through properly.
So our input types aren't coming through properly.
So I think there's a problem in
these the the two things that we specified
as arguments aren't actually coming through all the
propagating all the way through from the schema.
So let's take a look at that, see
if we can get it working.
That's not the right file, is it? That's
the other one.
Yeah. It's in the No.
One? It's in the production app. Yeah. That's
the one. Yeah.
Okay. Oh, you know what it is? I'll
I'll I mean, maybe you can spot what
it is. Yeah. You've already spotted it. Yeah.
That's why. So you can see there the
relationship between the schema and the actual strokes.
It's because so we'll need to regenerate the
SDK now.
Yep.
So make generate, make build, make install.
I've got this. I know what I'm doing.
You're a hero, man.
You're doing a better job at the developer
advocacy part than I am at this point.
So
Well, Paul's given us some hints for this
mistakes we're making along the way in the
chat as well, but I'm just gonna ignore
him because he left us.
Alright. So we'll give us a few seconds.
I don't think we need to change anything
on our TypeScript side. Right?
We're linking to the dependencies.
So really, if we just run a Pulumi
up again, hopefully, those two parameters are being
pulled through correctly and we'll get our deployment.
Okay.
Pretty magic if it works.
I mean,
like, obviously, the the this is the first
alpha ish release of a very, very powerful
thing. And part of the reason why I
wanted to do this live with you is
just to kinda get an idea of obviously,
I'm pretty close to it. So I kind
of know all the little things that we
need to iron out, but being able to
explain it and see those things. We've got
a lot of you know, we've got some
really exciting authoring improvements coming through as well.
So we expect this to kinda get better
and better over time.
Nice.
I think it's definitely solving a real problem.
Like I said, you know, I I work
in cluster API bindings that are using Pulumi
and TypeScript, and they're not consumable by people
that don't wanna use TypeScript. And like right
away, I could just see that I wanna
go and do this and generate the type.
So the implementation language is almost irrelevant to
a certain point.
Yeah. Absolutely.
Alright. Let's go for it.
Let's see.
So
it should tell us it it should tell
us it wants to update the deployment because
that never got created.
And the service has changed, so that sounds
like it's a good sign.
It worked. Let's create a replica check.
Deployment initialization complete. So now it's waiting for
the pods and images effect. It's already done.
And
if you so let's take a look at
actually how how long have we got left?
I wanna kinda run through some more. Yeah.
Ten fifty minutes. So
let's take a look at the SDK directory
and see what actually happened here.
So if we yeah. If we open up
if you look at the SDK, we generated
the things that all in dot and we
can write a go example as well probably.
But you can see, look, if you look
at the package dot JSON, it's just a
standard NPM
package,
which is called Rawkode.
This version gets like updated and it goes
into the bin directory. So that's what we
Yarn link.
So if you open up that bin directory
in Node. Js, you'll see that that should
have the correct version.
But you'll see, look, this is this has
got all the types and stuff that's actually
been generated for us.
And if you actually look the thing that
kind of is is crazy to me is
if you look at the deployment.d.ts
or the deployment.js,
all it's doing is deploying the the all
it's doing is creating the actual shape of
this thing. All of the work is actually
done in the Pulumi engine.
So it's not define it's not we're not
generating
a Pulumi program.
We're just generating
the types and the schema, and then the
Pulumi engine does all of the work,
which I think is just wild. Right? Like,
I think it shows the power of the
Pulumi engine to be able to to to
show that you can kind of do these
things.
And then there's also the Python SDK as
well. So that obviously is is available to
us. Your favorite one. Right?
My favorite.
What I'd like to do if we if
we could see if we can get it
work with with replace is do a go
version of this as well.
But again, like, this is the part this
is just, you know, the the input types
that we've got for each of the different
SDKs.
And that's basically it. Like, you know, we
we've we've generated a
consumable
thing. And and some of the things that
I keep thinking are like, I created a
Pulumi AWS load balancing controller
multi language component, which I think is an
amazing use case for this because if you
think about AWS load balancing controller as an
example,
generally to install it, you're gonna need at
least two different things to actually get it
working. You're gonna need CloudFormation to deploy the
AWS IAM roles and all that kind of
stuff that it needs to use. And then
also something like Helm or Kubernetes YAML to
deploy the Kubernetes parts.
With the AWS load balancing controller Pulumi multi
language component,
it just works. Like, it it deploys everything
in one go.
And I'm really excited about creating things like
production ready implementations of Helm charts is a
really, really good example.
You know, rather than kind of running a
bunch of Redis replicas inside,
you know, inside Kubernetes, you can use your
cloud providers hosted Redis,
to to be able to do that. And
I think Paul already mentioned he did a
amazing implementation of Google Cloud's Cloud Run multi
language component, which allows you to just specify.
All you need to do is specify an
image,
and it deploys a multi region global
Cloud Run
across all of Google Cloud's infrastructure
in a single line of code.
You know, like, it it's so powerful. And
the other thing as well is if you
are writing things like Terraform modules or all
that kind of stuff or CDK constructs,
you can essentially write these Pulumi multi language
packages. And instead of kind of going into
one
ecosystem,
either the HCL ecosystem or the AWS ecosystem,
you can go to all of our supported
language ecosystems and all of our supported cloud
providers. So the reach is really, really, really
far.
Awesome.
Very, very cool.
Well, all of your bits work. I'm I'm
now really curious if my bit worked and
whether I can actually browse to this application.
And my fear is no, but
damn.
Maybe
did we specify a port?
We didn't specify a port. Oh, we did
80. Yes. And there's NGINX, so it should
be working. Oh, well.
Well, there's something for me to fix later.
What I will do is just put forward
to it.
Least I can pretend some of my stuff
works.
80. 80. 80.
Hey.
Look at that.
It's the simple things that keep me happy.
So what I what I'll be what I
like if if you if you commit this
to Git hub,
you know, this is a great like kind
of like teaching example,
like a nice and simple straightforward example of
a multi language component.
Again, one of the things that's missing here
is you're probably going to want to pass
the load balancer output to other Pulumi resources
or maybe the namespace that's been created. So
the next step will be to add those
outputs, and that would again go in the
schema.
So you would say the URL, for example,
is a great way of kind of exporting
that thing. And then again, you can pass
these things and create dependencies between these things.
So you could say, let's say you wanted
to register a DNS name for the IP
address, you could use another Pulumi provider like
the cloud platform Cloudflare provider,
pass that output into the DNS output and,
you know, you're kind of off to the
races basically.
Nice. Awesome.
Very, very cool and powerful system for working
with Pulumi. It's really cool to see that
and just
I'm really impressed that it worked.
Well, I mean, only like I said, they
they I'm I'm pretty happy. The only problem
we had a problem with is the is
the JSON
schema.
We know that there's improvements needed there and
we're gonna you know, we're working hard on
those those kind of improvements. But it just
shows you handwrite something and you're gonna have
problems, right? Like
Yeah. But those things, right? Like improving the
authoring experiences you measure. Those are just quality
of life things. People can,
you know, start to take advantage of multi
language runtimes and packages now allowing them to,
you know, just like you said, deploying to
Kubernetes and Helm charts. Like, being able to
have idiomatic or convention based approaches per organization
or per team and satisfying that through Pulumi
packages is a pretty solid way to start
to start doing that. Yeah. We've had we've
had, like, large large customers who have large
engineering organizations
who are, you know, seeing the capabilities of
this and realizing that, you know, it means
that they can can bring in different organizations
who perhaps don't want to write things in
go,
perhaps don't wanna write things in TypeScript.
You know, they're they're multiplying their capabilities and
it we have companies who customers who are
creating internal SDKs
that kind of abstracts all of the stuff
away in similar way that we did
to allow them to kind of really provision
infrastructure really, really quickly.
Awesome. There's just two small questions if you're
happy to take them and then I'll I'll
link Would love to. Get back to your
day.
So, Fanny asks, is it open API schema,
the schema dot JSON?
No. It isn't. It's a it's a structure
of the actual internal Pulumi,
schema, which is not open API. It's all
done over gRPC and protocol buffers.
It's mainly just a it's just mainly just
a declaration of what things look like.
If if we think I don't think there
would be much value in turning that into
an open API schema.
We are documenting the skipper schema and maybe
we could use open API to make sure
that everybody knows what that looks like. But
the best thing that you have right now
is just to take a look in the
example that we put together and kind of
fill it out from there. I think you
should abandon the JSON and and use queue
for this, but I'm I'll I'll preach the
q goodness to you another day.
We got I'm still I'm still in the
JSON at church. I haven't come out from
that yet. So Alright. Last question, Andreas, who
also thanks us for the bleeding edge demo.
I'm gonna show that again because, know, as
I do appreciate you joining me today, Lee
and walking us through this. But Andreas asked,
is this the same
quotes magic
that allows us to use the providers as
they're based on the same system as the
providers being concerned for multi languages?
That is exactly right. Yes. So what we've
done here is we've taken the magic that
we have with our providers
that we use to like, when we bridge
them from TerraForm providers, when we create the
Kubernetes and as your native providers, it's the
same technology.
And what we've done is just kind of
extend it into Pulumi components, and we register
those components inside the actual Pulumi engine.
So
the great thing about this is if and
when we add another language and we're still
talking internally about what that language might be
and when that when that will be, I'm
sure I'll get messages asking for Ruby and
Java and all that kind of stuff after
this. Rusty. Rusty,
we haven't made decisions about this yet. But
the point I'm gonna make is when we
do add support for that language,
updating to that version of the SDK, let's
say hypothetically
hypothetically
people,
when we add Java support,
all you'll need to do is update to
the latest version of the SDK and it
will generate those language bindings for you and
you will get you know, every single time
Pulumi will add a new language SDK in
the same way that we get for the
providers,
like Java support will come in.
You know, it will happen for the components
as well. So it's exactly the same technology,
super powerful,
you know, magic, you know, Isaac Asimov said,
you know, indistinguishable
from magic. Awesome.
Alright. Pulse taxes, can't wait to see those
Equinix metal packages. You're damn right. Those are
coming soon.
And we've got one last question from Andreas,
and then that's it. I'm leaving it there.
Andreas is asking, could you say some words
about the isolation between two components from a
runtime perspective?
Read NPM dependencies.
Does that make sense to you?
I think so. If I'm not getting this
right, Andres, then please feel free to reach
out to me on Twitter at Brigzel. Essentially,
the the the the runtime dependencies are basically
because we built this in Go, we obviously
need to actually bundle the Go dependencies into
the binary, which is know, from a user
perspective, like, not completely transparent. They don't need
to know about that.
When we generated the SDK, if you remember,
we looked at the schema dot JSON really
early on and we defined what those runtime
dependencies were because we know we're gonna use
the Kubernetes SDK.
And so that when we generate that SDK,
for example, NPM or PIPE, it generates a
package dot JSON with those dependencies in there.
And so you as the user have full
control over what dependencies the the thing needs.
An example that I put to that I'm
putting together right now is,
you know, you might
one the things I'm gonna write one of
these in Python, god forbid. But
I'm also going to try and update the
and it's gonna be an IAM type provider
that uses parliament
as a,
you know, as a linter for those IAM
profiles
sorry, IAM policies.
That will need to be installed when you
actually kind of install the the component itself.
But you have control over what the user
installs. There's no cross dependencies between these things.
So,
you know, as a as a Go author,
I don't need to tell them to install
any Go modules or Python modules. It's just
the actual runtime that they're selecting. Selecting.
Awesome.
Alright. Thank you very much, Lee. It's always
a pleasure to spend a bit of time
with you even more so when you're showing
me Pulumi awesomeness.
If if anyone else does have any more
questions, I've stuck Lee's Twitter handle on the
screen. I'm sure he'd be more than happy
to help you. He's also very active in
the Pulumi Slack, which I would encourage you
all to join and ask loads of awesome
questions about this magic that is happening here.
Any last words, Lee?
No. I I really appreciate,
kind of spending time with you and not
being under the pressure of fixing a Kubernetes
cluster. So,
yeah, it was really great, and I'm looking
forward to kinda coming on next time we
have more awesome features and showing them off.
Awesome. I cannot wait. Alright. You enjoy the
rest of your day. I'm gonna finish off
today. I will speak to you soon. Everyone
that watched, thank you. Have a great day.
Awesome. Thanks. Bye.
I just clicked finish, and it said video
not found. So we're gonna do this lo
fi. Bye bye.